so we are at big air trampoline park now
it's been a while since I've been here
but we're doing something really fun hi
Josh
don't you seen hey Internet you're
pretty famous for your Halloween
costumes so what's happening today
yeah so this year for Halloween I am
dressed as Tigger from Winnie the Pooh
here's my head pretty please so it
turned out like the legs are just
there's perfect amount of floppy so when
I jump it's a custom-made costume
obviously you can't really buy these in
stores so these are fake legs attached
to the body and then my leg is in the
tail and the tail we use like this sort
of elastic to create that sort of
fatigue spring look but he is known for
I don't really like it I think it's a
hilarious costume
it's like really uncanny to see like
coordinate bounce like that they like
sort of flop up in the air it really is
awful what was your like when you walked
in and saw it what was your first
feeling when I walked in I was just like
oh oh my goodness I think Ashley may
have been filming while I was just in
shock because it just looks so crazy
like you're bouncing around at a
trampoline park I mean the irony is just
it's unbelievable like at first I was
thinking oh I'll just get some photos of
me standing and I was like no it's a
ticker like obviously you should be
bouncing because that's what he does and
we got slo-mo bounce which is very very
important
[Music]
fun funfun
but the most wonderful thing about
Tiggers is I'm the only one I'm the only
one bigger di double gutter
oh happy Halloween happy Halloween you
just see Hillary in the Internet make
sure you guys go check out Josh I cannot
wait for you to see his full video
[Music]